this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the Thursday November 15 2012
session in our series on green
technologies and transportation want to
welcome everybody here today I'm Richard
Dasher I direct the u.s. Asia technology
management center that produces this
series of nine seminars and like to
especially recognize Sunbridge partners
for providing additional financial
support for our series so we'll have
some refreshments outside thanks to
Sunbridge be sure and not stay around
and meet our speaker and and talk with
each other after the session is over
also want to mention that yes next
Thursday is Thanksgiving Day so of
course we will not have a session then
two weeks from today we have mr. Steve
Center who is a senior executive in
charge of the environmental business
development unit for Honda Motors so we
have mouths v's coming back in two weeks
and then our final session in this
series will be december six with mr. lou
thompson who is very high up in regard
to high-speed rail and advises the state
of california on high speed rail issues
we're going to ask what California
should learn from asian high-speed rail
today we're covering a segment that so
far we haven't gotten to very much in
the series ii bikes and to come and
present to us today we have Nick Rothman
and nick is known really well in two
different technical areas first as
plug-in hybrid conversion so Nick
co-founded a company called green gears
in 2007 and green gears is basically
pushing a smart transportation to the
consumer one of the things that Nick is
currently involved in is doing all the
installations and customer support for
a123 systems plug-in hybrid conversion
systems he's the lead tech on toyota
prius plug-in hybrid conversions for
PG&E google san francisco city and
county UC davis and a lot of other
organizations Oh Nick also in the East
in the ebike space is founder of a
company called extreme green machines
which was a large bicycle electric
bicycle and scooter rental shop in San
Francisco Nick currently directs all of
the ebike um maintenance work for
blazing saddles which is the largest
bicycle rental organization in the
United States I think they're up in the
city and he's the author of two books
the electric bicycle handbook and also
the homemade plug-in hybrid so Nick
thanks very much for coming today we did
the introduction but currently I'm
maintaining a fleet of electric bikes
for blazing saddles you may have seen
these bicycles cruising across the
Golden Gate Bridge or somewhere else
this is the largest bicycle rental
company in the United States and what's
really cool about their operation is
they've found a way to use ebikes
profitably so ebikes you know as a mode
of transportation it's sometimes it's
hard to really break down the economics
of one mode of transportation versus
another but in terms of rental this is a
really a profitable game and it allows
them to really invest some real money
into buying e-bikes maintaining e-bikes
trying new technology blazing saddles
seven locations in San Francisco largest
bike rental in the United States so when
we think about the bike mark
it just to kind of quickly go over it
you look at that this is 2010 clearly
china is where most of the e bikes are
if you look at that little blue sliver
that's the United States so you know
we're not a very big piece of the pie
with the ebike market so i'll start with
the Chinese e-bike now I'm going to go
over the the other ebikes out there and
and other things but it's interesting
because the Chinese e-bike if you look
at this they are really unique I mean I
never see these types of e-bikes in the
United States they just they really
don't make it over here these racks for
instance I mean this bike is totally set
up to be a very functional vehicle it's
a lead-acid battery if by the way if
anyone has questions i'm open to taking
questions as i'm presenting as well as
in the end so another thing i'm looking
at on this bike that i think is
interesting it's hub motor and if it's
really unbelievably inexpensive i mean
this this type of chinese e-bike some of
them are selling for two hundred dollars
in china I mean I it's hard to even
really understand how they're able to
produce them at such low prices and
they're just selling millions and
millions of these so here's the motor
now this this is yeah i'm going to go
over some of the points on the chinese
bike technical aspects of it so you see
here this this is a chinese-made motor
the
mono you see written here that's
actually just the sprocket set so that's
made by another manufacturer and screwed
on there but the Chinese hub motor is
the direct drive type on most of these
Chinese bikes and it's extremely simple
and very cost effective so this is
actually the technology that's moving
most of China and it's it's incredible
how it really doesn't get much attention
because it kind of goes under the radar
it's their kind of funky and small and
no one's really you know talking about
them that much but they certainly are
out there and huge numbers now if you
look here here's a hub motor being made
now what I find interesting about these
is in terms of the production they wind
them by hand and we really don't hand
wine motors in the United States or
Europe or Japan but they've just found
it to be more cost-effective it's and
it's it's a very functional method they
just have a you know simple kind of
old-world system where they they kind of
use these pieces of folded paper as a
guide and it's just like weaving a
pattern and they they just crank them
out that way there was a nice row of
finished motor Staters here now in the
United States we do import these hub
motors and one manufacturer I was
working with as a technician actually
requested a production change instead
will agree to buy a hundred units of
your motors if you make a very minor
change I mean nothing that would require
new molds or anything I think they just
wanted one of the like a little resistor
placed on this card and the manufacturer
responded by saying we make 10,000
units a month so we're not going to make
any change for a hundred units and it
kind of brought the reality to us that
you know buying 100 units seems like you
know an order worth noticing but to them
they're just they're production levels
are almost unbelievable any bikes going
to have petals okay okay is there
anything in the size of the motor that
salsa or the power of the motor that is
kind of a difference the motor power
level is is kind of by region so it is
interesting how they break that down the
United States is the most generous
they're they're giving you 750 watts
which is pretty significant if you ride
a 750 watt ebike it's got a lot of power
the Japanese actually define it as a
ratio of how much power the bike is
putting in compared to the amount of
pedal power you're putting in and then
it's capped at a certain top limit the
Europeans just say 250 watts so everyone
has their own kind of set of guidelines
but basically you'll see an e-bike will
have pedals and a motor of a certain
output okay if you look these are
electric magnets and these are permanent
magnets and the motor is just energizing
the electric magnets and sequence and
making it chase I mean it's there's
nothing new happening here people were
doing this a hundred years ago which is
part of the reason it's it's really just
so cheap to make these especially when
you're making them by hand and one thing
we have noticed in the the ebike world
is the tolerances really don't matter as
much as you would think now when you
have a car and your crowd
testing it you're driving 100 miles an
hour on the freeway tolerances are
important but when you're going 20 miles
an hour down the road I've seen some of
these things we're just the you wouldn't
think it would run some of the holes
have been drilled by hand at times or
production errors like little fixes and
they just happily chug down the road and
no one really knows the better so it's
just incredible what you can get away
with I mean so here we are at the
Chinese the internals of the Chinese
electric bike hub motor and this outer
shell as the holes for the spokes where
you see them here and there it's just
lined with magnets and they're glued in
by hand and then the inner core here has
these windings on it that are hand wound
and then the only really you know modern
electronics in here are these little
these three little sensors and they've
actually recently devised a system to
even get rid of those so when I look in
this thing it looks like like a toaster
or something inside to me I mean it is
just dead simple and these can
especially the versions without the
sensors you they have bikes that they
run through creeks you know them then
flooded it's it's not waterproof it's
just that it's so simple it doesn't
matter if water gets in there it just
leaks back out there's nothing just
metal you know coils of wire so they're
really the the moving parts on this
motor are the two bearings on the axle
that's it it's just metal coils and
magnets that will come out of the other
side okay through usually through the
end of the axle
now a little twist on it that they've
come up with is a small gear set we're
going to this is a planetary gearset
just because of the formation of the
gears there's the Sun the planets the
ring so this is an identical motor that
has just a miniaturized gearbox stuffed
in the shell with it and this will be on
like a higher-end Chinese e-bike what
this does for you is it allows the motor
to spin at a higher rpm and the way I
describe this is if imagine you had a
car and you had to just choose one gear
and that gear happened to be fourth gear
well you would need an incredibly huge
powerful motor to make a car just drive
around in fourth gear so because of the
lack of any gear reduction in a an
electric motor that's just simply built
into a wheel it's basically like be it's
a direct connection so it's the same as
your fourth gear on a car so that's the
reason they have these huge heavy hub
motors on a lot of these Chinese bikes
is because there's there's no way to put
a gear reduction so they've devised this
still cheap and simple but requires
quite a bit more in terms of keeping
track of tolerances parts count so a
motor like this is probably you know
direct from china maybe in the two
hundred dollar range the previous more
simple version of the motor is maybe
more in the forty or fifty dollar range
so or even less I mean you know they're
there are other I think the the higher
quality Chinese stuff gets imported here
but some of the domestic stuff is maybe
you know twenty and thirty dollar motors
that they're able to produce there's
another Keystone to the Chinese electric
bike is the wet acid battery
and another tried-and-true technology
here it's very effective I mean it's
it's not the best item to to get
Americans excited about electric bikes
because it's heavy and you're not going
to have much range but they sure do work
and I've you know I've always expected
that the Chinese would change over to
lithium batteries but they seemed
perfectly happy with those you know 120
million electric bikes on the road there
you know pretty much all lead acid and
one of the big reasons behind that is
there's just there's no electronics here
again you could literally submerge this
battery in water and nothing would
happen to it it would be fine about how
much of the time would somebody be
pedaling and how much of the time of a
let the battery take over well it's
interesting because with the let's go to
this this is the control system on the
Chinese electric bike the throttle so
you're acting as the computer there is
no software so if I want to go far I'm
not going to twist it very much and i'm
going to pedal a lot and people just
kind of learn by doing and they they
realize their limitations by testing it
these these uh lights don't really
accurately show you how far you're going
to be going just because they're not a
sophisticated computer that's really
counting the amount of energy going past
it's just kind of a dumb light system so
it's basically going to tell you your
lead acid battery is dead when you can
already tell it's dead because the all
the power is gone one of these things oh
yeah i mean i i've got so many like when
you're pedaling is it really clunky I
mean is it really hard to make it go
just rickety clunky squeaky
you know the brakes don't stop very well
and but but nobody reliable they do work
yeah what uh so in the u.s. I guess we
would want kind of a more sophisticated
look and feel oh yeah the people that
ride bikes just don't want something
that's no way yeah they won't go for it
yeah I mean we couldn't rent these these
bikes now here's what what we're going
to have in our bikes here this would be
nicely packaged in a shell but this is a
lithium battery pack so if this were a
good quality pack these cells would say
maybe Anna sonic Samsung some major
brand battery manufacturer and one of
the issues you've got with lithium
batteries is this battery right here
could be ninety eight percent full and
this one might be ninety-three percent
full and this one some other percentage
they're all in the same range but
they're not just totally perfectly even
in terms of their charge so what they've
done to compensate for the natural
imbalance of all these lithium batteries
is this this circuit here so this
circuit we're calling battery management
system BMS and you have a row of
resistors so if you imagine that you
have a battery that you want to bring
down to the level of the other batteries
because one battery just is too full and
it's going to eventually overcharge
because this bike is charging and you
want to fill up all the batteries but
you don't want to overcharge any battery
because then you've ruined that cell and
there goes the battery pack so what they
do is if you'd imagine attaching a light
bulb across one of these cells the light
bulb would illuminate and draw power
from the cell and then it would give the
other cells time to catch up to it
because it's not going to be you know
it's going to be losing charge as that
light bulb is connected so instead of a
light bulb they're using
these resistors there's one resistor for
each cell and the little circuit can
turn each resistor on independently and
that is the predominant strategy for
lithium battery management that's in my
laptop that's in every electric bike
with a lithium battery that's into wall
drills that's in Toyota Priuses it's
it's just you know the way they do it so
it's it's effective but again it's
complicated adds cost these lithium
batteries of course just blow away the
lead batteries and performance you're
talking maybe a fifth the weight is just
much more pleasurable to to ride with
without that huge weight yeah just like
how how far with a lead battery taken in
battery take you like one mile 10 miles
well I mean it a lead-acid powered ebike
you're probably going to be in the 10 to
20 mile range and the web lithium
powered e-bike you probably push that
out too more like the 20 to 40 to 50
mile range and even with a you know
maximized range of 40 and 50 miles that
would still be a lighter weight bike
than the lower range LED bike speak up
we want everybody know it assuming when
you mentioned range but assuming sale on
average 150 pounds person what sort of
speeds are so many people still 100 mile
an hour electric bikes there they're out
there just in as your average consumer
product is going to be limited right at
20 miles an hour on the nose because
that's the federal law but maybe you
mean what kind of speed gain would you
see from switching to lithium serious
well let's feed all
American domestic e-bikes just power
cuts at 20 miles an hour state of
California which has two categories of
motorized bicycles now I own one and
it's legal at 30 miles an hour so long
as you have a motorcycle license and a
helmet right right and I'll tell you
that 30 miles an hour is a wonderful
addition and when you're even handed out
of their lazy bikers here on campus or
other no your makes me partly with
traffic or something the ability you're
going 20 miles an hour and you want to
accelerate you can do it yes it's a real
safe you know you've all seen the
pictures of the hordes of bikers in
China all puttering along the same
modest speed we know we aren't there yet
so an individual like me have to watch
out for himself and having this extra
power of very much with that kind of
lithium battery system it really matters
so if anyone is thinking about 1 i'm
happy the talk is upstairs well and it's
expensive but i will recognize recommend
a 30 mile an hour version over the 20
yeah good point sara is there a
differential in the charging sort of
characteristics between oh yeah i mean
the lithium just wins in every category
you'll charge a lithium battery and half
the time or less you can quick charge
them the lead batteries just can't
absorb the charge very quickly it's a so
you'll see these lead batteries sitting
on the charger for eight hours and it's
you know 95% charge but you could leave
it for a few more hours to get the last
bit and the lithium's just boom they're
done you know they're they work great
yeah so you mentioned earlier that
Chinese people are typically happy with
the missing there as a battery no but
you see that's primarily because of the
cost or cost and durability should I be
so if you have a battery that costs you
know three to five times as much and
doesn't
asked any longer in fact it might have
some issue if you were to drop it in
this board cracked or got wet or it's
not just solid as a rock like those lead
batteries that are practically
impossible to break cycle right the
newseum ion batteries that's maybe
thousand times of of charging whereas if
countries could ask couple hundred times
or sorry I don't see that in the field
work I don't ever see a thousand cycles
some of them are saying three thousand
cycles I don't know I mean I've read the
reports but I'm not seeing it i don't
think the lithium is really i I think
you 500 cycles is what you should expect
from a lithium yeah but close yeah a
little bit less so you go ahead you
first asked how much traditional cost
does the lithium-ion battery pack ad and
do you think the consumer will pay for
that there's so like well European
Japanese and American consumers pretty
much are into the lithium batteries it's
an easy upsell and it you know it's two
and three times the cost for the same
capacity so good entire bike for further
yourself so what how much will it cost
people for differential be so you'll
have a two-hundred-dollar LED battery
and a six-hundred-dollar lithium battery
all right if i'll cover some more bikes
from you know other markets one last
thing before you get to that oh one of
the complaints that you hear from people
in the US that are kind of selling bikes
and so forth is that the maintenance
requirements for an e-bike is are very
hot you've always got the thing in the
shop always working on it yes that's
true
the with the real simple cheap stuff in
China do you ever hear anything about
well maintenance situation I think one
of the differences is that once you get
to a critical mass where there's a real
market for a product the shops will come
so you know in Asia there they have e
bike shops that are capable of repairing
them on every corner pretty much I mean
because there's just millions and
millions hundreds in China so they have
that covered one of the big issues here
is you know there were plenty of regular
bike shops you'd never really be stuck
you know with a issue with your pedal
bike but there's just no one to work on
them because there isn't enough of a
market so it's this kind of chicken and
the egg thing but as any vehicle it's
going to need service definitely the US
for a $25 5 4 s he says the third mouth
I'm not sure exactly it's hard to know
should always that at the big annual
event of bike manufacturers and dealers
that took place in Las Vegas about six
weeks ago called interbike yeah but
you're probably going to mention four
major manufacturers specialized swim
Trek and giant all introduce new ebikes
yeah and the 1500 to 2000 price range i
think yeah so they're all pushing for an
answer to your question yeah and there
is so there's no not answer and as usual
there will be the early adopters uh and
I'm one of them my bike is custom made
so what we have here I'm just going to
kind of quickly go through the rest of
the pieces of the Chinese bike is this
is the controller so what this does is
it interfaces between the battery the
throttle and the motor and with the the
type of motor they're using you have to
have a controller it's not just adding
some functionality or you know cool
features if you don't have this these
motors won't run that's because
everyones using brushless motors on e
bikes and with without the brushes you
need this little box and again it's just
literally amazing they're making these
and selling them for twenty dollars and
it's something that you look at it and
it seems like it would cost a couple
hundred bucks I mean there's some real
high powered electronics in there and
once you get to this you know tens of
millions mark with production they
really work out the bugs in these in
there you know there are various
versions so these have really come a
long way in the last five or so years
here again we have the the throttles
that are going to connect to that and
that's just that's the the interface
with the the rider
and charging the battery of a
where they go downhill some of them will
ya if you apply the brake on the Chinese
bikes yep you apply the brakes and
you'll feel an engine brake kind of a
sensation as if you down shifted your
car and you know you're slowing with a
nice even drag and it's returning energy
to the battery so that that works really
well with the brushless motors and it's
it's built into a lot of those twenty
dollar controllers just as a basic
function it's not on all of them so here
it's is using the classes machetes and
goods clothes yeah I'm sure there are I
mean there's safety issues with
everything though I mean it they the
frames will break and things will happen
for sure but the plane uses rims yeah ok
I just couldn't quite ok so here we have
a totally different animal the Japanese
e-bike and I mean if you look at this
the engineering is it really incredible
with these and I just want to describe
what they're doing here they don't have
a hub motor on this bike there is no hub
motor here the motor is here and what
what you're able to do instead of being
stuck in fourth gear like I was talking
about with the big heavy Chinese ebike
you've got a you know like a nice
shimano internal gear set or a
derailleur and you as you shift the
gears here you're also shifting the
gears that the motor is driving so now
you can have a motor than that weighs
maybe a third the weight it's just more
efficient it's more complex these
Japanese bikes are also extremely
durable but not not because of
simplicity they're just highly
engineered so here here it is this is
here's the pedal and the chain actually
runs over this
little drive sprocket and then back down
so this guy turns with the motor and
since the pedal crank goes through this
motor box it knows how hard you're
pushing on the pedals and reacts with
that kind of a ratio I talked about
that's that's determined by Japanese law
where they say well if you push with 5
foot pounds the motor can push with 10
foot pounds but no more so it's got
torque sensors and software and you know
very engineered product panasonic and
yamaha are the biggest makers big names
you know these things are engineered
well and again they've worked the bugs
out on these they're lithium batteries
are excellent they they have these
systems that lock it in place this is
where the battery sits on all the
Japanese e-bikes it's almost
standardized I mean they've pretty much
have it right there which is excellent
for the wait it's also you know just a
good secure place to put it it's locked
in place various frames they've they've
kind of been plagued with the the frumpy
look with the Japanese spikes but you
know it's it's what people buy their
they're selling again selling millions
in Japan actually yamaha did more
electric two-wheelers than then gas two
wheelers last year in Japan so the
numbers are big they're taking it
seriously and they're they're not just
doing the the ebike thing too because
they think it's interesting there's real
money in it but they're increasing or
kind of just doing well until their
market share yeah yeah they're
increasing yeah I just read a report
from one of the big vendors of e bikes
in Japan and
they said they were they were growing
ten percent a year and they're battling
it out panasonic and Yamaha they're just
advertisements everywhere there it is a
big deal in Japan saying that they're
selling more e-bikes than they are
motorcycles yeah yamaha sold in japan
now you have to realize in japan if you
want to get a motorcycle license it's no
laughing matter i mean you're going to
spend a few thousand dollars and take
courses for weeks and weeks and it's you
know the registration and everything
it's a total pain so there's it's kind
of understandable why a lot of people
would maybe just go the easy way and
grab the ebike electric scooters fall
into the continuum well here they don't
have you mean that the little like
kickboard types or the the Vespa type
here they're having a tough go at it
because once you get a motorcycle
license now you're free to just grab any
motorized vehicle that also requires
insurance in a plate and you can get a
parking ticket so at that point once
you've gone through the trouble and
expense a lot of people will just get
the honda scooter the gas-powered Vespa
because one of the huge advantages of
the electric bike is that you don't need
registration you don't need insurance
there's no plate on it that falls away
when you go with the Vespa style so
that's killed the market to a certain
degree for the electric at least one of
the things about the electric scooters
is that I used to be able to take hills
better right because I had more power
it's what I well is used to but if you
get the licensed one yeah young woman's
life motorcycle sure yeah but said the
750 watts will really climb a hill ok
the Japanese are 250 and but they're
they're just so efficient and you know
that it it's really it's you have to
pedal though is the other thing you
can't just sit there there is no
throttle
these it's just sensing how hard you
pedal so you can't sit there and just
cruise you're always pedaling which is
kind of annoying if you're into e vikes
you know and what's the deal so that's
the law so they finally kind of decided
to make some e-bikes that that look a
little sporty-er an interesting thing
about the Japanese take on it is you
know you can have a cool screen you can
you know learn what you're doing you
know how far you've gone battery state
of charge one of the things i find
interesting though is that they really
don't obsess on the quality level of
their bike components in japan if you
look at these bikes they've got just
really cheap brakes and derailers just
super low-end stuff like you know this
this is basically a Walmart bike with
their drive unit on it and it's great
because the thing costs 1200 dollars
it's really cheap here people are really
in the United States people seem to be
very conscious of you know well do I
have dr XD or is it dr LX and in japan
people don't even seem to know what
component is on their bike and they're
able to sell a much cheaper bike of
course it doesn't you know it's not as
polished in terms of the drivetrain but
it's just the market over there these
are their kid carrying options are just
excellent I mean the a lot of the people
may have seen the cargo bike thing
that's that's kind of gaining some
momentum here where it's a you know a
long tail bike and they have like a seed
attachment but with these Japanese bikes
they really i mean there's seat belts
there's little wind visors they have
whole catalogs of options and in the
thing is that when you're selling
millions of units you can work through
the initial cost of having a whole book
full of accessories for your product
line we're here we haven't quite
hit that so we're still kind of there
aren't as many choices so here we go
European e-bikes the Europeans an
interesting thing they've got some
really nice e-bikes this is the smart
belt drive it's got a three speed hub
integrated into this motor really nice
controls you know it's an expensive bike
I think this is going to be four
thousand bucks or three thousand bucks
it's going to be expensive but you know
they've got some nice stuff what's going
on with the fork is there something
there is that just style that's just the
look yeah so they think about the look a
lot the Japanese it's just whatever
performs the functionality of carrying
the intended cargo is perfect you know
but but people really want to want a
nice looking bike in Europe and one
interesting thing is I've seen a lot of
these this is a german-made frame
top-of-the-line components and that same
old panasonic drive system in the middle
but now it's a three-thousand-dollar
bike and it's yeah it's better than that
Japanese bike but it does have the same
motor and battery exactly like there is
no it's you know it's not even branded
differently says panasonic right on it
so the Europeans said well you know we
don't want to ride with these junk
components but we do like the Panasonic
drive and they said well let's just make
something exactly like that that's
that's ours so the bosch and the bashas
is going to be on a lot of bikes soon
there's going to be a cannondale with
the Bosch system there they're going to
be out there it's exactly like the
Panasonic and the yamaha it feels the
torque that you're putting into the
pedals you've got a pedal it's got the
screen as an option if you want the
you know the information the battery
goes right in that same spots got the
lock so that's the Euro take on it and
and you're still not gonna be able to
cruise you still can't Cruise yeah yeah
unfortunately the now I wrote this at
interbike it's it's very polished it's
really nice so you know I've got high
hopes for for this system and the bikes
that it comes on it's it's still kind of
unknown i mean i've seen some estimates
but i think it's it's going to be on a
lot of 2013 bikes it just kind of
released that so here we have the
American e-bikes now this is a moped ish
setup you know you this is all about the
cruise I mean you really you could pedal
sometimes if you felt like you wanted to
but the huge tires it's got a lot of
drag they've got this roller here I
maintain a fleet of these in these are
about 80 pounds they're pretty heavy and
you know heavy hub motor but people love
renting these I mean you just hop on and
just it doesn't require that you go a
mile or two an hour before the motor is
active you can just turn this thing on
and just crank the throttle and it goes
from a stop so it's it's basically a
moped I mean a moped that falls within
the laws of electric bikes you don't
need a license cruisers are big in the
United States so branded cruisers this
is a ped go again they just grabbed a
like a direct drive Chinese hub motor
all the components are Chinese but
they've just kind of reworked it into a
more stylish package but none of the
American manufacturers seem to be making
any of the components at all
like maybe no I don't think they're
making any of the components so it's you
know the rebranding thing I mean they
take a lithium battery I've seen various
brands on all the different American
bikes they kind of shop around test some
stuff make some deals with the
manufacturers and then that's that's
their technology and interestingly one
of the phenomenons in the United States
is the conversion bikes as Americans
it's interesting the conversion thing
the custom bike is big in the United
States and Australia some other areas of
Europe some some areas of Europe as well
but of you know in in Asia people aren't
they don't want to make their own bike
they they want to buy a bike in America
people just love making these
conversions so some of the makers of
these kids have really done well they've
actually done had more profitability
than a lot of the finished bike makers
you've probably if you did a lead-acid
kit you'd probably spend maybe five or
six hundred and if you did a lithium kit
you'd be up a thousand twelve hundred
for a low-end you know the sky's the
limit of course you could you could go
big and spend a lot
so the kits you get a box it's already
built in a wheel this is shipped
straight from China this is the motor
wheel from a bike that where they may
they're making millions of these so
they're not making any changes to allow
this to be a kit it's just this is the
way it already is and someone decided to
market this as a kit because
everything's in one box and it's a bike
wheel the batteries now one of the big
differences is that you're going to get
from one source the wheel motor
controller throttle in a box and it'll
be a separate source for the lithium
battery because these two things don't
usually come together on a Chinese
electric bike so they're two different
places making them and for my experience
these are pretty solid whereas the
lithium batteries that you're getting in
the kits since they're not pushing those
millions of units there are some bugs
you know there will be some batteries
that just don't last that long and don't
really live up to the expectations and
then we've got just this is the meat of
the American market it's not very clear
that that these are out there I don't
feel like this would be the hottest
seller but these just really cheap
electric bikes actually do sell pretty
well on Amazon and Walmart and let acid
kind of it it's not a Chinese bike but
it's just these are five hundred dollars
it ready to go you know you just pull it
out of the box and put the front wheel
on so so you're calling them walmart
bikes what kind of brands so they
actually have or is it Walmart around
its Schwinn okay Mongoose GT which are
all owned by the same company now so one
of the things that's happened is the
American market
has not performed to expectations so
I've seen one heavy investment ebike
startup after another fail because the
sales aren't what were projected and
what that's resulted in it a lot of
acquisitions you know this company
swallowed up that company so at
interbike we didn't nobody was hard to
tell who was working for who anymore
these some of these long established
companies had just got swallowed up in
the last year so the guys that are doing
all this Walmart stuff there they were
bought by a by a large European company
I can't remember what country they're
from Dutch okay and you know they've got
big presumably what would seem like a
good established market like they being
the leader in the United States you
would think that they would kind of have
some pretty decent cash flow but they
still haven't really did they continue
to kind of be fooled by this huge
expectation that didn't doesn't always
pan out so if you had to give like two
or three reasons why the American market
isn't growing like people are expecting
is it just bicycles are kind of four
kids and and not really for serious I
mean the serious riders are putting a
lot of money on by you know is it kind
of product image or is it safety
concerns or what what do you think that
it's growing it's just not doubling
every year because i think there's
nothing no data out there that tells me
it should double in the next year it's
just growing happily you know it's got a
nice five or seven percent for your
growth that's that's steady but i think
you know expecting these things to sell
is in huge quantity suddenly is I'm not
sure what makes people think that'll
happen but it it hasn't been happening
uh-huh
I bought two of Leo to lee iacocca sea
lice and the lead acid batteries in them
we're dead in less than six months so I
who want to be an enthusiastic promoter
I got the entire city council Palo Alto
to ride my bike with six months later I
have to tell them you know what it's
died on me to meet at the massive
shortage of product in this country for
leading-edge consumers to try to take to
play with if you can find him and having
to do a custom modification now there
you got something but in terms of it
will be open over-the-counter market
didn t have been very very porous on the
supply side I can take it a shot at teva
coca I think partly I mean the bike dish
we've shown the u.s. is really through
bike shops right and identify shops not
that's a world of passion right i mean
it's because people kind of like livin
love bikes and you know that's the meat
of the market like you said and that's
just not a product that speaks to
anybody who is that passionate bike shop
retail and so I think they just
struggled in the retail channels to kind
of find a home in tan part of it yeah
yeah there's only I'm thinking about the
country's I twisted that have little
higher demands those countries are
population and poorest in the u.s. you
have this lot of suburban areas that are
very spread out where you way you only
way really can get around it by driving
so i'm wondering if like the only places
i can really address are you know for
this type of a products you know it may
be a city Amish here that's more metro
oh I don't know yes actually we can look
at that a little later kind of country
by country I've got some some recent
data on it so I mean if you traveled to
any the country's all show may bring to
mind why they're working well in some
places and not others so finally we do
have some really high-end bikes here I
just assembled
one of these uh about two days ago and I
was pretty impressed it's a $15,000
electric bike made in Colorado it's you
know very well sorted as you would
expect crew for that price point it's a
crank drive and it does have a throttle
and it's 750 watts and it really does
work great and made one by one out EE
bike yes this one got a lot of press I
mean this thing is just incredible this
bike has a wheelie mode where it will do
a wheelie on its own and hold it
meanwhile an alarm goes off so you
realize you're in wheelie mode if you
want to flip it off if you don't know
what's happening this thing is just
incredible twenty one hour on this high
end stuff is they have like a road trail
switch or other ways to kind of get
around that 20 mile an hour limit this
this bike actually in all fairness these
guys came before the Audi bike so the
Audi you know it seems like you're
getting a lot more for your money but
they're a huge manufacturer and really
for Audi the press release related to
this was worth the entire development
costs and you know the black trail group
they're trying to actually you know make
money on each bike so they had to charge
quite a bit more but it's you know all
carbon fiber pretty incredible
yeah yeah that sounds right opta by the
$15,000 Colorado made one they call
themselves the Ferrari of e-bikes a lot
of the super high-end stuff is about a
custom super low production quantity
crank drive because now you've got your
through the gears you can change the
gear ratio of your motor you don't have
to have a motor that's as heavy as a
brick and you can get the most out of
your power it's the high-performance
setup and so they've got you know these
motors that they're you know they'll
have a few motor engineers on staff and
they really you know make the whole
thing so also I thought I'd go into
energy consumption a little bit because
it is that is one of the things that
that's really incredible about the ebike
it is so efficient just the platform
even the lesser efficient Chinese
e-bikes it's just incredible what they
do if if you kind of get a feel for
energy like in the electric car world
people talk about kilowatt-hours a lot
and it's it's just almost negligible
what you're going to use to to charge an
e-bike because it feel it seems like
logically it would be some quantity of
energy because it's replacing so much
work that you would normally do pedaling
but the vehicle is so lightweight you
know you're driving around in a car
that's 200 times your body weight and
that's that's where all the energy is
going so with you know when you have a
50-pound e-bike it just doesn't take
much energy to move the thing around
yeah just for completely best
and I have essentially retired our
family second car and my yamaha motor
scooter in favor of my e-bike partly for
calls partly for comedians and variety
of other things but that costs think is
very real no more trips to the gas
station very convenient yeah just for
comparison the test water performance
pack is 85 kilowatt hours and so that
lame about give you 300 miles now yeah
on a good day right now of course that's
a whole car but think about it one
kilowatt hour is giving you 50 miles on
yeah yeah it's just so you may you may
wonder where is this electricity coming
from this is worldwide so it's yeah it's
kool pretty much that depends on where
you live North America conventional
there's some renewable uh I mean the
point i would make about all this is if
you wanted to find a renewable solution
to charge your ebike it wouldn't be very
expensive and it wouldn't be very
difficult but then again if you didn't
you still wouldn't be burning much coal
to charge your e bike because it's not
it's like leaving the light in your
closet on while you are away for the day
I mean it's just it's almost like you
wouldn't even see it on your bill but
you could probably do a lot more to
conserve energy with just you know
buying a smaller TV or something I mean
I don't know where to start but the
ebike would not be an energy hog among
most of the other household appliances
you're going to have so the energy
source is worth considering as a
something to know about but it's
important not to forget just how
efficient these things are they had a
greater ratio of renewable to
conventional is that just all hydro some
biomasses
n0 that's so bizarre I need to do some
type of your in ethanol I'd goodbye so
again this is 2010 21 million that they
did in that year but they're the
estimate there's a hundred and twenty
million on the road because that's just
how many that one year Europe 700,000
Japan four hundred thousand nine states
300,000 I mean we kind of have a lot of
people considering we only did three
hundred thousand units so you know I I'd
be interested to see how this looked if
you adjusted for the population because
you know Japan a lot of people are
buying electric bikes there you figure a
hundred and thirty million people in the
population versus two hundred and fifty
or sixty in the u.s. right right so now
this is interesting set pike pike
research which is a reputable research
firm they're thinking about the next
five years or so six five years six
years pretty much seven and a half
percent per year nice and steady that's
what they think is going to happen so I
mean if you read a headline that you
know by 2018 there's going to be in an
additional you know so many million
e-bikes that could be misleading it's
actually it's just a nice steady growth
that they're projecting pretty much all
the regions are kind of steady growth
this this is this is us down here just
you know they went a little farther with
it at this point they're they're going
15 years out or so from now so they
broke it into two lines
be aggressive yeah I mean it shows a lot
of growth but it's just is it the aging
population that makes it slow down I
don't know I have a feeling that around
Twitty you know 22 23 you're starting to
see the population age and so these
might be less popular with that now
sorry I think that it's kind of rumor
asian population that's the focus market
yeah so I'm just noticing why the why
the line suddenly slows down and see
2020 you know or 20 25 and what people
with the gist seat-of-the-pants kind of
guesstimate on what the market is going
to do this is this is what people think
it's going to do oh my god it's going to
go through the roof but it's I mean so
this was really to me an important
statement that Pike Research made so do
you see any sign that the Japanese
domestic I knees domestic makers are
going to try to jump into other markets
well there's a regressive in mark in
selling units that I don't see why they
would I've actually seen a model where
you have a Chinese product that's not
going to amazon or Home Depot first
where they've actually got a decent
website and you have no idea this isn't
an American company reselling Chinese
merchandise until you finally click ship
and you go oh three weeks to get here
that's kind of odd oh well but I'm
starting to see that with with products
that i buy through American retailers
anyways so I think they will be able to
make a jump into our market without
having a major I guess part of the issue
is whether the domestic growth inside
the Chinese market is going to be so
much that it takes all of their
production capacity to keep up with that
I don't know because they don't really
need big machinery investment they're
making this stuff by hand they just you
know more people you know crank it out
but I think it's probably true that
there is very little chance of North
American or European ebike selling in
big quantity in China aware that the
opposite is even though Audi has a great
brand yeah so I think that's about
that's it for thanks very much Nick I do
want to open the floor to questions and
comments oh go ahead you know what I I'm
grief is very a what a broad 0 for the
pasta make this technology is excitement
for you because I have some friends were
really excitable the key box in in Japan
enjoy themselves very much I don't see
big not like a cool this was kind of you
know issues but it isn't coming from
almost looking like city like stevie
shae like Kovac it's very convenient for
that life so for me you want to screw
this a technology me what you want to
end systems like resource or energy shoe
something different like changing
lifestyle human society context or
whatever so I want to know kind of
complex you really are love you excited
well personally growing up in San
Francisco was motivation to find a
better way I'd you know cars towed
parking tickets on and on and on
discovered the bike and felt more mobile
of course I could take the streetcar
around but I kind of want my own
transportation and it was really benefit
for me for years I've had just dozens of
e-bikes and and I used them and they're
effective for me to to move myself
around so that was
to make sense I think it will they'll
make sense for other people out there of
course to it's just to kind of interrupt
for a second I in terms of who's in the
audience I think we've got at least a
couple of people who are actively
involved in the ebike business are you
Adam Adam foamer with Faraday bikes
would you say just a second about who
you are and what you're doing thanks for
the chance great talk so my name is adam
i'm the founder of a new bike company
based here in paola to actually so we
make a kind of on that higher end of the
US domestic market a bike aware you were
really sort of trying to approach it
from the philosophy of designing a bike
that people who love bicycles and we're
riding bikes can really get behind so
it's a beautiful clean elegant electric
bike with a relatively light assist kind
of more of a European style yeah it is
beautiful yeah I saw it in her bike
greenland by 13 years sir a welfare divx
com and yeah but it's also great and
you've made several comments today could
you identify yourself and tell us just a
little bit about your bike are you doing
this as a business or is this strictly
your own my name is Jeff I went I'm a
four-year girl graduate from the
business school I'm doing this strictly
on my own because I think the internal
combustion engine is a disaster for
short-range trips to completely
irrelevant and unnecessary at least on
flat ground it's not so good when it's
cold and wet but i just turned 70 and i
would like I want literally thousands of
people to experience the quiet the power
the fun the social connection it's a I
also what happened to by serial number
5107 of a brand new
shooter in 1978 from a company named
Apple so I consider myself an early
adopter when I can be so I look forward
to getting chatting with you and so
forth I again say my wife's upstairs for
anyone who wants to look at it our
budget okay great as anybody else
involved in making or selling e-bikes in
the group how about riding the bikes
that's ridden my bike okay anybody have
any kind of comments about what the
experience was like why aren't these
things more why are they more popular in
the US well if you want to exercise best
that's the reason I don't have anybody
ah and I have a related question which
is you gave this the cost per charge but
really the batteries over let's say a
year plus more than the electricity that
right yes about how much is a lead acid
battery and it's what every six months
perhaps might have to replace all I mean
every car or any vehicle is just wears
the parched out as you go it depends on
you can make wet asses last two years
you could get two weeks out of it
probably average may be an easy year out
of them Nick can I ask can I ask for a
comparison an automobile lead acid
battery runs about four years and cost
you a hundred bucks or two right right
so what about one for a bicycle well the
bicycle it's gonna have a harder life
because it gets drawn down uh-huh so
you'll have you know a shorter life span
significantly like a car battery if you
do everything just right you're only
asking for the smallest little drop of
energy to crank the engine over no
and you'll see as your car battery gets
old you leave your headlights on for
just five minutes and it's it's over you
know and then that's that's your clue
that that it's getting to the end of its
life but the electric bike starts to get
really annoying because it's a you know
your range is droppings and that happens
within a year usually or well I mean it
there's a lot of variables like with a
lead acid battery the battery actually
starts to corrode inside when it's empty
it's as if you had you know a piece of
steel in salt water you know that's the
chemistry when it's discharged when
charged it's not eating itself alive so
if you leave your lead acid battery
sitting there empty it it just rusts
away inside so it's kind of a factor of
you know how much time did it spend
sitting there not full and how much time
did it's been full so if you're really
diligent about plugging those LED bass
as two batteries in right when you get
off the bike you can get you know a good
you know three four years out of a pack
you see golf carts get treated well a
lot because there's a you know there's a
cord right with the parking space and
they get a long life out of the pack and
it's always it's on a fixed loop so it's
known where it's going to start and end
and it's car number seven goes in
parking spot number seven and there's
the charge cord the e-bikes tend to kind
of sit there someone took a ride forgot
to plug it in so that's when you really
kill your LED ass battery in the six
months okay it's just that people
shouldn't expect to have a car or a
vehicle that runs for ten cents a day
that just is not realistic and if
valuable shouldn't go into it with the
idea then oh here's my great and not to
reply directly to the gentleman over
here but your vehicle didn't die the
battery with that you know and that's an
expected part of the cost and my point
is just what is that cost and it's
totally
it's more like 50 cents a day than it is
ten cents a day is that not this is that
right I you know I don't know I have to
kind of pencil out the call it I mean it
I mean just for like rats like like a
pinnacle to your life maybe 600 bucks so
50 cents a day with charge on top of
that I mean it's you know under a dollar
in it I think it's got if you look at
the net net compared insurance
maintenance tysharaw girl it's cheaper
it's not that's it yeah yeah yeah and I
you know I've seen so many variables you
know like with the some people they're
just going forever and ever and other
people it's one thing after another and
you know I sometimes I'm not sure if
it's because they're riding style or did
they just get a lemon but you know as I
was a technician and mechanic at the
toyota dealer and people would buy a
brand new corolla and the thing was just
it you're not expecting any problems but
it would just be one thing after another
there are lemons out there and so
there's just so many variables but I
think if you're going to have if you're
going to own and operate your own
vehicle definitely there are going to be
a lot of costs associated with it he
bikes included but the charge data is
just I think too important to to realize
that you know it is in terms of energy
consumption very efficient so are we
going to see new approaches to charging
I think like direct things to you know
your own little solar panel I've seen
yeah I've seen a few cool examples you
know I think it could it wouldn't be
very expensive or costly to or complex
to to set up solar charging for an
e-bike as compared to you know some of
the setups I've seen a Tesla with the
solar awning over it it's cool but it's
you know you're you're spending a lot
more money to go solar on that car and
there's a lot more involved in it yeah
when you say in the US so many
automobiles on the road either by Cody
bike you always don't feel very
comfortable to share the road with oh
ok so you willing to expect the market
of their bicycles to go up very much you
have to share the road with so many
other yes although I do think we've seen
a lot more bike lanes appearing I mean
some of them are kind of if you sort of
have to have a death wish to write down
some but I do think that you're seeing a
lot more I've been fascinated to hear
that Blazing Saddles is so successful in
San Francisco and you know you can take
it around and you go for a day and rent
the bike for a day you don't have
trouble parking which is a huge issue in
San Francisco and you know you can go
out take it out across a golden gate
bridge a little bit and that's pretty
neat actually I saw your hand first go
ahead motivation for let acid the cost
because if you can compare like victim
iron deficiency in the energy densities
this it's incomparable right so if you
talk about like the light and durability
in terms of just like physical shock
type issues like crashing the ebike
things like that oh yeah definitely
essentially it doesn't have those are
you know those circuits yeah yeah I mean
it it's it's something that could be
engineered out of the equation like the
panasonic battery is in a really nice
hard case you can drop that thing it is
you know the way they've made digital
cameras where the circuit is designed to
be dropped but when you have kind of a
first gen set up in terms of just the
physical layout of the battery they are
they can be sensitive so i think i think
it's worth remembering that a bike is
actually into pretty severe
environmental conditions yes maybe even
more so than a car because you don't
have all of the suspension to kind of
keep vibration from getting even worse
I'm afraid we're going to have to end
the formal part of the session today
and we've got some refreshments outside
please join me in thanking it for a
great talk
you